ومجموعة فاغنر هي التي تقود
حرب بوتين الآن. الآن أنا
أحقق التقدم الوحيد المعروف في
ساحة المعركة لبوتين وهذا يعني أن الرجل الذي
يدير أقوى جيش خاص في روسيا
يصنع اسمًا لنفسه هنا
إذا صرحت جيني باجوسيان علنًا
أن رجاله هم الذين استولوا على
بلدة خارج مدينة باكموف الرئيسية مباشرةً،
يمكننا أن نقول بأمان أن مستوطنة
كليشيبكا، التي تعد واحدة من
أهم ضواحي باكموت، قد تم
الاستيلاء عليها بالكامل تحت سيطرة
وحدات فاغنر PMC حصريًا من قبل فاغنر.  لقد
تم تحرير وحدات PMC كليش،
إنه أمر لا يصدق حصريًا من قبل فاغنر.
فاغنر ليس الدفاع الروسي،
وليس الجيش الروسي، إنها
مجموعة منفصلة وأنت تؤكد على هذه الكلمة
حصريًا أنه هو وليس هم،
وأنه يأخذ الأمر إلى أبعد من
ذلك.  كنت أنتقد
القادة العسكريين الرسميين في روسيا علنًا، لقد
اكتسبت أعمق تجربة قتالية
منذ ثماني سنوات حتى الآن، وقد تفوقت في كثير من النواحي إلى حد كبير
على تجربة أولئك الذين
كانوا في خدمة
وزارة الدفاع لعقود من الزمن،
إنه أمر لا يصدق، وما هو أكثر ما
لا يصدق بشأنه.  كل هذا إذا
بدا أن فلاديمير بوتين على ما يرام تمامًا
معه وربما لهذا السبب
يسعد السياسيون الروس أيضًا
بدعم البروجوسيان في نوع من البريجوسيان
مقابل المؤسسة العسكرية الروسية،
فقط انظر إلى هذه الصورة من
المشرع الروسي البارز سيرجي
ميرانوف حتى تتمكن من  أراه هناك وهو
يحمل مطرقة ثقيلة، إنها
مطرقة فاغنر الثقيلة، هذه صورة استفزازية للغاية
لأن فاغنر يتفاخر
بامتلاك المطرقة الثقيلة كرمز
رسمي لهم، فلماذا لماذا لأنه تم
استخدام مطرقة ثقيلة لقتل
مقاتل من مجموعة فاغنر الذي حاول الفرار من
ساحة المعركة  في العام الماضي والآن انظر إليه
هناك وهو يلوح بها، وبينما
يعاني الجيش الرسمي الروسي من
نقص في كل شيء
أساسي تقريبًا مثل الذخيرة عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالقتال، يبدو أنه
يحصل على المزيد من الأسلحة من
سلسلة التوريد المملوكة بالكامل له  بإلقاء
نظرة على هذه الصور، سأعرض
لك هذه الصور التي نفهمها أنها
صور لما يبدو أنها عربات السكك الحديدية الروسية التي
تسافر إلى كوريا الشمالية لالتقاط
صواريخ المشاة والأسلحة الصاروخية
التي وفقًا للولايات المتحدة، توجهت بعد ذلك
مباشرة إلى الباغوسيين و
مقاتلات فاغنر في أوكرانيا والقلق
الليلة هو أن كوريا الشمالية قد
تقدم معدات عسكرية أكثر فتكا
إلى البروجوسيان على وجه التحديد